man all these classes look amazing i
can't choose
they do this thing called a shopping
period where you can just sample as many
classes as you want
sports and society physical science
a crash course yeah but it's not what
you think oh
i did not graduate college because i did
not attend it
but i'm trying to improve myself so i'm
gonna start by taking just one class
if you're gonna take a college course
andrew you should explore a new subject
broaden your uh your horizons are dumb
never broaden your horizons
yep just take something you're great at
and get an easy a no offense ron but
april's way sounds way easier guitar for
beginners
can't believe we're at hogwarts no
that's
buckingham palace hogwarts is fictional
do you know that it's important to me
that you know that
morning andy
okay something is different about my
computer
aha it's gone oh
a game is the foot see part of the
police academy entrance exam
is investigating a crime so about a
month ago i told everyone in the office
that at some point they should steal
something from my desk so i could
practice
let's do this wait
hey do you guys take my glasses too i
got my sunglasses too
i need a few more volunteers andy will
you be iceland the bad guys for mighty
ducks too
don't think so okay how about japan the
bad guys from karate kid too
even worse how about germany they've
never been the bad guys
why don't you be finland okay okay hello
everyone
my name is professor barnes the class
i'll be teaching this semester
is introduction to lasers the word laser
stands for light amplification by
stimulated emission of
radiation where are the lasers this
graphic here
represents the electromagnetic spectrum
arranged from low frequencies not even
using a laser pointer
you can see that's right this class
stinks stick with it he might learn
something
all right excuse me professor hi there
andy dwyer
curious when will you be bringing out
the lasers for me to play with
and would we start with the small lasers
or we could we go just straight to the
big lasers
in terms of playing with them we won't
be using actual lasers in this course
it's about the theory that makes them
possible
one of the most significant bummers of
my lifetime
three four five
six hey how you doing
what are you doing andy i'm getting
healthier snacks for the shoeshine stand
chris is a food genius
did you know that the food you eat
becomes energy yeah boom that's
spaghetti
nachos it's a cookie
that's my husband
leslie hey check it out just practicing
isn't that polish gonna get on people's
butts when they sit down
no hey ron
can i ask you kind of an important
question you know like when you go to
the atm
and you get money is there an actual guy
standing behind the wall who slides
dollar bills in there
no yeah this is robots oh actually you
know what i do have a serious question
in a movie predator
can you rub any kind of mud on yourself
to prevent predator from seeing you with
this thermal heat signature
okay if you're allergic to any food
we'll know in a few days
i think based on the redness i might be
allergic to getting stabbed by needles
we have already been to like five
different doctors uh i got my ankles
microwaved
x-rayed they took my blood away to use
for science cholesterol tests april had
her sinuses removed looked at some guy
looked at my wiener
touched it that was weird and that guy
wasn't even a doctor
that what
well the numbers don't lie i'm a goofus
not a gallant
what does this do
andy you coming out tonight part owner
of the club
uh yes let me ask you a quick question
what's the youngest a girl can be that
if
we go out i'm not a total scumbag you
know the old rule
half your age plus seven half my age
plus seven
oh okay well i'm 29 so half of
29. add seven
that's only 20
is 20 20 years old one
21 and a half 21 years old and a half
yep yep
we got the same thing with the equation
on that one
oh my i have two partners often at the
same time
wow thank you does anyone know what we
risk
when we have unprotected sex hardest
things
broken yeah dies on top of you yes but
the truth is the greatest risk you face
is sexually transmitted diseases
are these old people really having sex
with each other yeah what did you think
they were doing i don't i don't we're
just talking about it
the best way to prevent them is okay you
can take a class on the civil war
why don't i take a class on something
that's already happened look you guys
have already had your say
now i want to try something that i want
to try and i'm gonna make my choice as i
always do
at random
as she was burned at the stake joan of
arc did not cower
she did not beg for mercy she said in a
strong
clear voice i am not afraid i was born
to do this
i want to be burned at the stake
hello andrew what's new
um a whole lot check this out i just
invented it
super straw
what's this dragon fruit
what's this a kiwano or horned melon
what's this
a peach i knew that
wow fresh lettuce is my all-time
favorite food what's your favorite food
oh i take skittles
and i put it between two starbursts you
know what i call it
skittle sandwich that's pretty good no i
call it andy's mouth surprise
it's nice because the the flavor of the
starburst really bring out a
similar flavor in the skittles
that class was awesome i wholeheartedly
agree
if that woman weren't so violently
opposed to marriage i think i would
propose to her
well then it's decided andy dwyer will
be taking
women's lasers women's studies sorry god
i cannot stop thinking about lasers
women's studies is there such thing as
women's lasers that'd be my number one
pick
hey why don't you um sell your banned
cds here that is a brilliant idea
i cannot believe i didn't think of that
i have been writing a lot of songs about
shining shoes lately
i tend to write about what i'm doing i'm
talking about
writing about what i'm doing
now i'm singing about talking about
writing about what i'm doing
ladies and gentlemen put your jazzy
hands together for my man
mr duke silver
a smooth and silky evening to you all
on nights like this when the cold winds
blow and the air
is awash in the swirling eddies of our
dreams
come with me and find safe haven
in a warm bathtub full of my jazz
[Music]
can i help you maybe i was out of the
jazz club last night
scouting bands for the unity concert and
i saw something
very interesting
you have a twin brother what
i have a twin brother yes
i am duke silver
do you remember anything about a key or
april doing anything unusual that day
she did make us stop by the shoeshine
stand before we left because she wanted
to drop something off for andy
she had a real bad crush on him oh
babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing
we're married still to the shoeshine
stand
the receptionist says she'll fit you in
as soon as there's an opening
if you're all right i'm going to head
back to the park
liquid do you know what my social
security number is
or if i'm allergic to anything i don't
like corn
should i put that down or will that be
confusing because i do
like candy corn oh
ron what a mess
here let me help you all i wanted was
two hours where i got to forget
that i was a parent look i found all
three differences
those are two completely different
pictures
you